- Welcome back.
At just six years old,
our next guest became
a symbol of a movement.
In 1960, in the wake of
a Supreme Court ruling,
she was escorted by four Federal Marshalls
into a previously all-white school,
becoming the first black student
to attend William Frantz
Elementary in New Orleans.
The scene was chaos,
protestors shouting and throwing things.
White parents pulled
their kids out of school
and only one teacher, one,
agreed to teach the student.
So for a year, she was
escorted by federal marshals
into an empty room where she
was the only kid in the class.
Today, that young girl has
become a civil rights leader,
continuing the fight.
And she has a new children's book
detailing her childhood experience
called "I Am Ruby Bridges".
Let's welcome Ruby Bridges, everybody.
(audience applauds and cheers)
Oh, my gosh.
It is such a pleasure to meet you.
I'm running this through my head.
'Cause I have a six year old
and an eight year old and I
can't imagine sending them
into that situation.
That must have been so daunting as a kid,
but maybe you were so young, you know,
it hit you differently.
But you say that going to
school, that first day,
you knew that something special was going
like you were special
in some sense, right?
- I really did
and it was because I'd
already gone to kindergarten.
So, I thought I knew what
to expect from school,
but this was definitely
something much different.
And I did feel special
because I remember having to take a test
and having people come over
to the house to congratulate
me for passing the test.
So, that made me feel special,
but not really knowing what was to come.
I mean, I was accustomed to Mardi Gras
and I remember Federal Marshalls knocking
at the door and me getting
into the car with them,
escorting me to school,
but actually thinking
that it was Mardi Gras because I was six
and had no idea what was
happening at the time.
- It's so powerful and it's so,
I read to my kids every night
and I love always,
first of all, thank you.
I love having a new book.
'Cause we read the same
ones a lot of the time.
So, it's nice to have that,
but also it's an empowering
thing to show them
and tell them this is a true story
and like educate them from
a young age in that sense.
So, thank you for that.
Just as a parent reading
to your kid every night.
(audience applauds)
It's so powerful and it's real.
You know, they read a lot
of fantasy things or
other things that aren't
like real historically based things.
So, let's talk about that teacher though.
Her name was Mrs. Henry. Right?
Do you still keep in contact?
- I do, believe it or
not, she's still alive.
She lives in Boston and
whenever I'm in Boston,
usually every year I
get an opportunity to go
and visit with her.
She was an amazing teacher
and not really understanding
why that crowd was outside.
You know, I often say that,
once I got inside of the
building, she showed me her art
and I knew that she looked
like the crowd outside,
but she was different.
And it was because of the
love that she showed me.
So, I don't think that I would have gotten
through that if it had not been for her.
And the fact that she's still alive
and still my very best friend,
but also still a teacher.
Whenever I'm making a mistake,
she's definitely there to correct me. So,
- Huh.
- You know, we made friends
or life at six years old.
It was amazing.
- Yeah. Well, it was a beautiful impact
that y'all had on each other, you know,
probably a reciprocal.
So, today is an important day for you.
It's Ruby Bridges Walk to School Day.
So, what is it and how did that happen?
- Believe it or not, in
the state of California,
there was a group of fifth graders
who they have seen my movie,
read all of my books, and they thought
that I should have my own holiday.
And so, they worked
together to make sure that,
that happened by being in
touch with their senators.
And beloved and behold, last
year it became a holiday
in California.
So, Ruby Bridges Walk to
School Day is actually
a day my own holiday.
And kids get an opportunity to
come together when they walk
into the building just
as I did back in 1960.
They have an opportunity to
dialogue with one another
to make sure that they have an opportunity
to make a difference in the world.
So, I am extremely proud of them
because they're young
activists and you know,
we hope that
if schools haven't signed
up for Ruby Bridges Walk To
School Day that they will.
So, what better way to
celebrate November the 14th?
I am extremely proud of them.
(audience applauds)
- Oh my gosh.
And what better way to celebrate
and immerse kids physically
into teaching them something
historically as well
instead of just reading about something
or giving them a worksheet
or something like that.
Like I was that kid that
really loved to be immersed
in a situation and I
learned better like that.
So, I think doing that physical act
and doing things that
really point that out, like,
for kids is really important
and a really cool lesson.
I hope kid, I hope schools
rather do that as well.
It's really, a really a powerful thing
and a powerful tool to teach
your kids about activism.
Well, up next we have
an educator who's truly
walking the walk in
Charlotte, North Carolina.
He's the youngest principal
in the school's history
and he is all about making sure
his students know Ruby's story.
He doesn't know you're dialed in today.
So, he's gonna freak out.
Are you up for surprising him?
- Absolutely.
- All right everybody,
we are back and you know,
I'm all about educators who go all
out to inspire kids to
dream big and work hard.
Our next guest is doing
just that in his hometown of Charlotte
where he recently became
the youngest principal ever
from Movement Freedom Middle School.
Let's welcome principal.
(audience applauds)
Congratulations.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you.
- I have never heard of, you're 20,
you just turned 25 recently, right?
- I just turned 25 a
couple weeks ago, which,
- That's the youngest principal.
- It is, yeah.
It's the thing in our nation,
the average age of a
principal is 48 years old.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so, being a 25 year old principal
that was the thing I
used to set my children
like you can be young
and still do all the
things that you want to do.
- Yeah.
- You can be that principal
who's out in the front with
the boombox playing music,
dancing, high fiving all the children.
It's a thing.
So I wanted my children
to see that my age was
like gonna be an excuse
to not achieve excellence.
- Yeah. Oh, I love that.
(audience applauds)
Not use it as an excuse.
So, tell us about your school.
- Yeah, so our school,
we are a charter school
network in Charlotte,
North Carolina called Movement Schools.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Kenneth] At my school
specifically, we have 98%
of our students who are
black and brown students.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We also have sixth
and seventh grade students
who we love so much.
We're gonna add eighth grade next year.
And one thing I really love
about my school specifically is
in the nation there are only 2%
of men of color who are educators.
And at my school I have a plethora
of men who show up every day
giving our students their best.
- Yeah, I love that.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So you carve out special time
with the kids as well, right?
- [Kenneth] Yes.
- Okay.
- So, every week we have something
in all the movement schools
called community meeting.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And in those times is
when the whole great levels
come together
and we talk about like things
from systemic racism,
oppression, educational things.
And specifically this week, today
as National Ruby Bridges
Walk to School Day.
So, this week at Community,
meaning we're gonna talk
about like what was the
impact that Ruby Bridges had
on education and then how can you guys
as young leaders to have that
same impact in your community.
- [Kelly] Absolutely. Have
that fire, have that passion.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Well we love how you
connect with your students
and teachers on such a
deep and important level.
So, we're not the only ones.
In fact, we have someone dialed
in who wants to acknowledge
your achievements.
Yep. So, say hello to Ruby Bridges.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- Oh my gosh.
Hi.
- Oh my goodness.
- Youngest principal ever.
- I mean, is this not so impressive?
Kenneth is so impressive.
What do you wanna say Ruby?
- Kenneth? I just wanna say
that it is so heartwarming
to hear you talk
about kids the way that you do,
to also have you say that,
there's not enough African American men
in education today.
And I applaud you for
standing up and heating
to that calling because that's
what I feel like I'm doing.
I am heating to my calling.
And to have someone as young
as you do the same thing,
- Wow.
- That inspires me to
continue to do my work.
- [Kenneth] Wow.
- Ruby Bridges Walk to
School Day is about that.
It is about inspiring young
people to have them dialogue
to help them to understand
that they too can make a difference.
And that's all because of you.
So, thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
- Oh my gosh.
- Oh my gosh. You both are so powerful
and infectious and just
like great to be around.
Please come anytime.
So, what do you wanna say to Ruby?
- Ms. Bridges,
I just wanna say I'm thankful
for your boldness, your
confidence, your servitude.
The thing that you did so many years ago
is a thing that shapes who we are
as a people while we can walk
and understand the importance
of being in an equitable
place to like really learn
and understand who we are.
But it was you walking
into that school with all
the adversity, the obstacles,
the people who told
you you couldn't do it.
But you did it anyway.
And so, children seem
like this is a real person
who advocated professionally,
but also so confidently is
why they think they can
also do the same thing.
So, I'm so appreciative
for you, for your walk,
your journey and just the
bonus that you've shown
and that you continue to show even today.
- Oh my gosh.
(audience applauds)
- Well, I was just,
so that you understand,
I would not have been able
to make it through that year
if it had not been for another teacher.
- [Kenneth] Yeah.
- So, I am so proud that
you stepped up to the plate
to actually teach.
- Yeah.
- We have to continue to do that and fight
so that all of our kids
have an opportunity
for equal education.
- Absolutely.
- So, thank you for doing that.
- [Kenneth] Thank you.
- You are walking the walk.
- Absolutely. Thank you.
- I know Ruby, that
you have something else
you wanna say to Kenneth, right?
- Yes. I would love to
surprise him with something.
Kenneth. I wanna make sure that every one
of your students gets a copy of my book.
And if you let me, I would
love to be able to come
and visit your school
if you would allow me to do it virtually.
Would you?
- His actual head just exploded?
- Absolutely. Yes, absolutely.
Let's do it.
Oh my gosh.
- Yes, definitely.
- Oh my God.
- I mean, what a cool way to learn
for your kids to see like
the people who did that walk
like literally,
- This is amazing.
- Oh my God.
It's just powerful when
you're listening to
- It's a blessing.
- Y'all talk.
- Yeah.
- Well, your not being left out audience.
Everyone in the audience
is also getting a copy
of Ruby's new book.
- [Kenneth] Yes.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- Thank you so much Kenneth.
- Thank you for having me.
- So for being an educator,
- I appreciate it. Thank you.
- [Kelly] For being,
- Thank you.
- Such a positive influence
on all these kids.
- [Kenneth] Thank you
so much for having me.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you Miss Bridges.
- [Kelly] You're so powerful.
Thank you for empowering the rest
of us and keeping us
all bold and in check.